This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the late 1920s, the Ford Motor Company bought up millions of acres of land in Brazil. They loaded boats with machinery and supplies and shipped them deep into the Amazon rainforest. Workers cut down trees and cleared the land and then they built a rubber plantation in the middle of one of the wildest places on Earth. Ford's rubber development on the Tapajos River is an enterprise of historic proportion. Here, two million acres of jungle are being converted into a highly modernized plantation, capable of producing rubber on a large scale. The plan was to harvest the rubber and ship it back to Detroit, where it would be turned into
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。20世纪20年代末，福特汽车公司在巴西买下了数百万英亩的土地。他们装载了机器和物资的船只，将它们运往亚马逊雨林的深处。工人们砍伐树木、清理土地，然后在地球上最荒凉的地方之一建立了一个橡胶种植园。福特在塔帕若斯河上的橡胶开发项目是一个具有历史意义的企业。在这里，两百万英亩的丛林正在被改造成一个高度现代化的种植园，有能力大规模生产橡胶。该计划是收获橡胶并将其运回底特律，在那里它将被制成
tires and other parts for Ford cars. But Henry Ford, one of this community, which he called Ford-Landia, to be more than just a huge plantation. He wanted it to be a kind of industrial utopia. He paid his Brazilian workers good wages, at least for the region, and he tried to build them the kind of place he would have loved to live, which is to say a small Midwestern town. than the kind of place he would have loved to live, which is to say a small Midwestern town, but in the middle of the jungle.
轮胎和福特汽车的其他零件。但亨利·福特希望这个他称之为“福特兰”的社区不仅仅是一个巨大的种植园。他希望它成为一种工业乌托邦。他为巴西工人支付了不错的工资，至少在该地区是这样，他试图为他们建造一个他自己会喜欢居住的地方，也就是一个中西部的小镇。而不是他会喜欢居住的那种地方，也就是一个中西部的小镇，但却是在丛林中央。
Deep in the wilderness, this model community is self-sufficient in every detail. It has its own powerhouse, electric lighting, a telephone system, its own machine shop completely equipped with modern tools. There's a laboratory for processing rubber, an ice plant, and a fire department. You had a church, you had a hospital, you had a power plant, you had a big sawmill.
在荒野深处，这个模范社区在每一个细节上都是自给自足的。它有自己的发电站、电灯、电话系统，还有配备了现代工具的机器车间。这里有一个橡胶加工实验室、一个制冰厂和一个消防局。你有一座教堂，有一家医院，有一座发电厂，还有一个大型锯木厂。
That's Roger Weber. He's the host of a podcast called Miss Match. And this story is an adaptation of one that recently aired on his show. And so he wanted to create this village for the workers down in Fordlandia. And while it's easy to look at him as some greedy imperialist capitalist, very easy, he actually felt that he could help these people. The company hospital with a best of modern equipment and accidentally staffed provides free medical aid for the employees. Later an outdoor luncheon is served, followed by tempting delicacies. Then comes the afternoon round of golf,
那是罗杰·韦伯。他是播客《Miss Match》的主持人。这个故事改编自他节目中最近播出的一期。所以他想为福特兰的工人们创建这个村庄。虽然很容易把他看作是一个贪婪的帝国主义资本家，非常容易，但他实际上觉得他可以帮助这些人。公司医院拥有最好的现代设备和偶然配备的人员，为员工提供免费医疗援助。随后供应户外午餐，接着是诱人的美味佳肴。然后是下午的高尔夫球赛，
played on the plantation links against a beautiful, jungle backdrop. Today, the Ford Plantation is a successful enterprise, a tribute to skill and science, the new weapons of the 20th century pioneer. But the reality is that Ford Landia was not a successful enterprise, nor was it really a tribute to skill and science.
在以美丽的丛林为背景的种植园球场上进行。今天，福特种植园是一个成功的企业，是对技能和科学的致敬，是20世纪先驱的新武器。但现实是，福特兰并不是一个成功的企业，也不是对技能和科学的致敬。
It was a colossal, expensive, and tragic mistake, and it took Henry Ford nearly two decades to give up on it. It's a parable of arrogance, but the arrogance isn't that Ford thought he could tame and conquer the Amazon. Historian Greg Brandon. He had his sights on something actually much bigger. He thought he could tame and conquer capitalism, industrial capitalism.
这是一个巨大、昂贵且悲剧性的错误，亨利·福特花了近二十年的时间才放弃它。这是一个关于傲慢的寓言，但傲慢的并不是福特认为他可以驯服和征服亚马逊。历史学家格雷格·布兰登说。他的目标实际上要大得多。他认为他可以驯服和征服资本主义，工业资本主义。
Ford wanted to export his brand of industrial paternalism to the Amazon, pay workers well, and provide services so that they stayed healthy, productive, and most importantly, loyal to the company. And that didn't happen. In the early 1900s, a couple of decades before Ford set out to build for Landia, a massive shift was underway in the rubber industry. For years, Brazil had been the world's main supplier of rubber.
福特想把他的工业家长式作风输出到亚马逊，给工人高薪，并提供服务，使他们保持健康、高效，最重要的是，对公司忠诚。但这并没有发生。在20世纪初，福特着手建立福特兰的前几十年，橡胶工业正在发生巨大的转变。多年来，巴西一直是世界主要的橡胶供应国。
Pretty much all of the rubber went into bicycles, that went into condoms, that went into gaskets, that went into valves, that went into tires, all came from Brazil. And the way rubber was cultivated was very labor intensive. Rubber tapers would go out into the dense jungle and find rubber trees. They would slash the trees, and then they would extract the latex that flowed out the side of the trees, they would boil, in essence, this milky fluid and turn it into a large balls of rubber, which they would then try to sell. Passing it on this kind of very decentralized chain up until it wound up in warehouses in Manchester or in Detroit, rubber tapers would work part of the year tapping rubber
几乎所有的橡胶都用于自行车、避孕套、垫圈、阀门、轮胎，全部来自巴西。而橡胶的种植方式非常劳动密集。橡胶采集工会进入茂密的丛林寻找橡胶树。他们会砍伐树木，然后提取从树侧流出的乳胶，他们本质上会煮沸这种乳状液体，并将其变成大橡胶球，然后他们会试图出售。通过这种非常分散的链条，直到它最终进入曼彻斯特或底特律的仓库，橡胶采集工一年中会有一部分时间在采集橡胶
and they'd work part of the year growing other sustenance crops in order to survive. This was the economy that lasted for years in Brazil. But this economy could be brutal for workers at the bottom of the production chain. As rubber plantations grew, they struggled to find enough workers. Some rubber barons started enslaving indigenous people
他们一年中会有一部分时间种植其他维持生计的作物以求生存。这就是在巴西持续多年的经济模式。但这种经济对生产链底层的工人来说可能是残酷的。随着橡胶种植园的发展，他们难以找到足够的工人。一些橡胶大亨开始奴役土著人民
and forcing them to tap trees. Even the workers that were being paid didn't make very much. The so-called latex lords at the top grew enormously wealthy, living in palatial homes in gilded cities in the jungle. This system all started to change because of a British explorer named Henry Wickham. He'd come to Brazil to seek his fortune in the Amazon, and then in 1876. Henry Wickham managed to steal thousands of rubber plant seeds, and he sent them back to England and eventually they went to the English colonies.
并强迫他们采集树木。即使是那些获得报酬的工人也赚得不多。顶层的所谓“乳胶领主”变得极其富有，住在丛林中镀金城市里的宫殿式住宅中。这个系统因为一位名叫亨利·威克姆的英国探险家而开始改变。他来到巴西是为了在亚马逊寻找财富，然后在1876年。亨利·威克姆设法偷走了数千颗橡胶树种子，并将它们送回英国，最终它们去了英国殖民地。
There was technically no law at the time preventing the export of the seeds, but Wickham had applied for an export license under false pretenses. He smuggled the tens of thousands of seeds back to England in the hold of a steamship. Each seed was about three-quarters of an inch long. His entire seed cash weighed over one thousand pounds, and he may not have known it at the time, but his act of bio-piracy would totally transform the rubber trade. From England, Wicom's rubber seeds traveled to various European colonies like Malaysia, Sri Lanka, and Indonesia.
当时在法律上并没有禁止出口种子的规定，但威克姆是以虚假的借口申请了出口许可证。他将数万颗种子藏在蒸汽船的货舱里偷运回英国。每颗种子大约有四分之三英寸长。他的全部种子现金重达一千多磅，他当时可能并不知道，但他的生物盗版行为将彻底改变橡胶贸易。从英国，威克姆的橡胶种子传播到马来西亚、斯里兰卡和印度尼西亚等各个欧洲殖民地。
The trees thrived in these warm tropical environments where no blight or bugs had evolved to eat them. Growers set up plantations with rubber trees planted in dense rows, and these new colonial plantations ended up massively outperforming the traditional Brazilian rubber tapers. Say, around 1910 Brazil had, by that year, pretty much lost its control over the rubber industry. Meanwhile, the new European rubber barons were talking about setting up a kind of cartel. They now dominated the global rubber trade, and they realized that meant they could set its prices, which made a certain American industrialist control freak extremely nervous. Henry Ford was used to controlling everything. Well, a Ford Motor Company in the 1920s pretty much controlled nearly every raw material
这些树在温暖的热带环境中茁壮成长，那里没有枯萎病或虫子进化出来吃它们。种植者建立了种植园，橡胶树密密麻麻地种植，这些新的殖民种植园最终大大超过了传统的巴西橡胶采集工。可以说，到1910年左右，巴西在那一年已经基本失去了对橡胶工业的控制。与此同时，新的欧洲橡胶大亨正在谈论建立一种卡特尔。他们现在主导了全球橡胶贸易，他们意识到这意味着他们可以设定价格，这让一位美国工业控制狂感到极其紧张。亨利·福特习惯于控制一切。嗯，20世纪20年代的福特汽车公司几乎控制了制造汽车所需的几乎所有原材料
that went into the making of a motor car, the glass, the iron, the wood, the lumber, everything except latex. This looming European-controlled rubber cartel represented a big threat. If rubber prices went up, it could make the tires and gaskets and tubes more expensive. So Ford wanted to create his own rubber supply. But his problem was that rubber doesn't grow in the US. So not only was Henry Ford vulnerable, but Brazil was vulnerable. And that's why the nation of Brazil basically gave him this huge,
玻璃、铁、木材、木料，除了乳胶以外的一切。这个迫在眉睫的欧洲控制的橡胶卡特尔构成了巨大的威胁。如果橡胶价格上涨，可能会使轮胎、垫圈和内胎变得更贵。所以福特想创造自己的橡胶供应。但他的问题是橡胶在美国不生长。所以不仅亨利·福特很脆弱，巴西也很脆弱。这就是为什么巴西这个国家基本上给了他这个巨大的、
tractive land about the size of Connecticut to try to start his doomed rubber plantation. Brazil was placing a big bet, but betting on Henry Ford wasn't the worst idea. You look at a guy like Henry Ford and all he had achieved with the Model T and the $5-day wage, they're looking at a real opportunity. And who better than Henry Ford to come down there and had achieved with the Model T and the $5-day wage, they're looking at a real opportunity and who better than Henry Ford to come down there and restore that former glory of controlling the rubber market. It was a boondoggle from the very beginning.
大约有康涅狄格州那么大的土地，试图开始他注定失败的橡胶种植园。巴西下了一个大赌注，但押注亨利·福特并不是最坏的主意。你看看像亨利·福特这样的人，以及他用T型车和5美元日薪所取得的一切成就，他们看到了一个真正的机会。还有谁比亨利·福特更适合来到那里，并用T型车和5美元日薪取得成就，他们看到了一个真正的机会，还有谁比亨利·福特更适合来到那里，恢复控制橡胶市场的前昔荣耀。从一开始这就是一个浪费钱的项目。
The Ford Company shipped in supplies on the Toposhoce River. They brought in American managers and hired a Brazilian workforce. Then they started clearing the land to build, Fort Landia. The jungle, of course, is just a very challenging place. And right away, things started to go wrong. You have, for example, the workers who are trying to clear the land. They'd be working out their bear chested and would be suddenly
福特公司通过塔帕若斯河运送物资。他们引进了美国经理，并雇佣了巴西劳动力。然后他们开始清理土地以建造福特兰。当然，丛林是一个非常具有挑战性的地方。事情很快就开始出错了。例如，那些试图清理土地的工人们。他们会赤裸着上身工作，突然就会
covered with biting ants and hornets and scorpions and even worse they would reach in and suddenly a pit viper would bite them and kill them. So they were dealing with a life and death struggle here. Eventually the workers managed to clear the land and build a town in the middle of the rainforest, and Ford had a very particular vision for this town. He wanted it to feel like the small Midwestern town he associated with his childhood. He grew up in a farm. He believed that there was a kind of healthy connection between agriculture and industry, as crazy as that seems. He saw them kind
被咬人的蚂蚁、大黄蜂和蝎子覆盖，更糟糕的是，他们伸手进去，突然一条矛头蝮蛇会咬他们并杀死他们。所以他们在这里进行着一场生死斗争。最终，工人们设法清理了土地并在雨林中央建立了一个城镇，福特对这个城镇有一个非常特殊的愿景。他希望它感觉像他童年记忆中的中西部小镇。他在农场长大。他相信农业和工业之间有一种健康的联系，尽管这看起来很疯狂。他看到它们某种程度上
of intermingling. And he really brought these boyhood memories of the farm into his adult life, just this nostalgic yearning for a bygone era. This nostalgia was for a very narrow slice of America, small town, mostly white America. That was Ford's model for Fort Landia, even though he was importing it into a very different cultural environment. When you go to Fort Landia, there's an uncanniness to it, a familiarity. It doesn't seem exotic. It's very recognizable.
交织在一起。他确实把这些农场的童年记忆带入了他的成年生活，这只是一种对过去时代的怀旧渴望。这种怀旧是对美国非常狭窄的一部分，小镇，主要是白人美国。这就是福特为福特兰制定的模式，尽管他把它引入了一个非常不同的文化环境。当你去福特兰时，有一种怪异感，一种熟悉感。它看起来并不异国情调。它是非常可辨认的。
The company then set up Plantation-style rubber Fields, lots of trees, densely planted, in the style of the colonial rubber tree plantations in Southeast Asia. They started recruiting even more Brazilian workers from the surrounding areas, and a lot of them were excited to work for Ford. Ford was promising something they'd never really had, free health care, free education. He wasn't a guy just running roughshod over that area. He felt he could improve the lives of these workers. And this wasn't just Ford being benevolent. This was Ford being strategic. Back in the U.S. he discovered that if
公司随后建立了种植园式的橡胶田，大量的树木，密集种植，风格类似于东南亚的殖民橡胶树种植园。他们开始从周边地区招募更多的巴西工人，他们中的许多人对为福特工作感到兴奋。福特承诺了一些他们从未真正拥有的东西，免费医疗，免费教育。他不是一个仅仅在那个地区横行霸道的人。他觉得他可以改善这些工人的生活。这不仅仅是福特的仁慈。这是福特的战略。回到美国，他发现如果
he paid his workers well and let them work reasonable hours, if he didn't totally exploit them, in other words, he could dramatically reduce turnover. And that's what he wanted to do in Brazil. In a sense, they're trying to apply lessons from the factory to a plantation. That's exactly what they're trying to do. That's Matt Anderson from the Henry Ford Museum being interviewed by Roger. Try to run a plantation in South America
他给工人高薪，让他们工作合理的时间，换句话说，如果他不完全剥削他们，他可以大幅减少人员流失。这就是他想在巴西做的事情。在某种意义上，他们试图将工厂的经验应用到种植园。这正是他们试图做的。那是亨利·福特博物馆的马特·安德森在接受罗杰采访时说的。试图在南美经营一个种植园
as though it were industrial facility here in the Midwest. You know, bring in the time clocks, have the workers work eight hour shifts, clock on, clock off, serve them cafeteria style. industrial facility here in the Midwest, bringing the time clocks, have the workers work eight hour shifts, clock on, clock off, serve them cafeteria style. Why was that part of the world so forbidding to what he was trying to accomplish? Part of the problems were cultural.
就像它是中西部的工业设施一样。你知道，引入考勤钟，让工人们进行八小时轮班，打卡上班，打卡下班，以自助餐厅的方式为他们服务。中西部的工业设施，引入考勤钟，让工人们进行八小时轮班，打卡上班，打卡下班，以自助餐厅的方式为他们服务。为什么世界的那个部分对他试图完成的事情如此排斥？部分问题是文化上的。
People down there were used to living in a different way. They were not used to the eight hours a day, sort of factory clock shift that we're used to here in the United States. And part of that was with very good reason, the climate there's very different. They're just 150 miles or so from the equator. Temperatures routinely get well over 100 degrees during the heat of the day. They were used to going into work in the early morning hours before the heat really kicked up. Taking a break for several hours in the middle of the day and then coming back at the end of the day to finish up. And of course,
那里的人习惯于以不同的方式生活。他们不习惯我们在美国习惯的那种每天八小时的工厂时钟轮班。部分原因是有充分的理由，那里的气候非常不同。他们距离赤道只有150英里左右。在白天最热的时候，气温通常会超过100度。他们习惯于在清晨热气真正升起之前去工作。在一天中间休息几个小时，然后在一天结束时回来完成工作。当然，
that's not the way Ford did things. You'd punch in at nine, you'd work right until five, and that was it. Then, other problems started to become clear. Back in the States, Ford had created an industrial system where workers could actually afford to buy the products they made. But in the Amazon, there wasn't really that much to buy. There was no consumer society within the Amazon,
这不是福特做事的方式。你九点打卡，一直工作到五点，就是这样。然后，其他问题开始变得清晰。回到美国，福特建立了一个工业体系，工人实际上买得起他们制造的产品。但在亚马逊，并没有太多东西可买。亚马逊内部没有消费社会，
so they didn't actually need the high wages that Ford was promising. They would work a few weeks or a few months and then they would disappear and they would go back into the jungle to work their plots to produce their own food. And maybe they'd come back the following year. And this would drive the Ford managers mad.
所以他们实际上并不需要福特承诺的高工资。他们会工作几周或几个月，然后他们就会消失，回到丛林中去耕种自己的土地以生产自己的食物。也许他们第二年还会回来。这会让福特的经理们发疯。
If Ford solved the problem of turnover and Detroit, the problem of turnover in the middle of the Amazon at the top of Schoes River just proved insurmountable. The cultural disconnect also went beyond just work culture. And Reford had very particular ideas about how society should be arranged and what people should enjoy. For example, he loved square dancing. He met his wife Clara at a square dance. And so he figured, well, we've got this big hall down there in Ford Landia, and so let's
如果福特解决了底特律的人员流失问题，那么在塔帕若斯河顶端亚马逊中部的人员流失问题就被证明是无法克服的。文化脱节也超出了工作文化。亨利·福特对社会应该如何安排以及人们应该享受什么有非常具体的想法。例如，他喜欢方块舞。他在一次方块舞会上遇到了他的妻子克拉拉。所以他想，好吧，我们在福特兰有一个大厅，所以让我们
play some square dancing music. Address Platinum. Surprise, you know, it wasn't all that popular down there. Who would have thought? Ford was also a tea toater, so know, it wasn't all that popular down there. Who would have thought? Ford was also a tea-tother, so even though drinking was legal in Brazil, he prohibited alcohol in Fort Landa. Again, you have Henry Ford trying to impose his will thinking, well, it works for us in America. Although a lot of Americans at the time didn't think the prohibition worked, but he was,
放一些方块舞音乐。地址白金。惊喜，你知道，它在那里并不那么受欢迎。谁会想到呢？福特也是一个禁酒主义者，所以你知道，它在那里并不那么受欢迎。谁会想到呢？福特也是一个禁酒主义者，所以即使在巴西饮酒是合法的，他也禁止在福特兰饮酒。同样，亨利·福特试图强加他的意志，认为，好吧，这在美国对我们有效。尽管当时许多美国人并不认为禁酒令有效，但他，
by golly, he was going to make it work in Brazil. It turns out he wasn't going to make it work in Brazil. Some savvy entrepreneurs set up a bar and brothel on a little island near Fort La India. They called it the island of innocence. And they were technically outside of Fort sovereignty sovereignty or Ford's control, and they couldn't do anything to stop it. And then there was the food. Henry Ford was a vegetarian and an early advocate of healthy eating. And so he wanted them to eat whole wheat products, and he just felt that this was going to be
天哪，他要在巴西让它生效。事实证明，他无法在巴西让它生效。一些精明的企业家在福特兰附近的一个小岛上开了一家酒吧和妓院。他们称之为“纯真岛”。他们在技术上处于福特的主权或福特的控制之外，他无法做任何事情来阻止它。然后是食物。亨利·福特是素食主义者，也是健康饮食的早期倡导者。所以他想让他们吃全麦产品，他只是觉得这将是
better for their health. This actually led to a riot. The riot happened in 1930. Workers resented having to eat the exact kind of food that Henry Ford told them to eat, but the other problem was that they'd initially served lunch to the workers' restaurant style with waiters. Well then somebody got the idea, listen, we have the assembly line up in the United States. So let's have them eat cafeteria style. It's more efficient. We can keep track of things. Well, the workers absolutely hated that approach.
对他们的健康更好。这实际上导致了一场骚乱。骚乱发生在1930年。工人们反感不得不吃亨利·福特告诉他们吃的完全一样的食物，但另一个问题是他们最初以餐厅风格为工人们提供午餐，有服务员。好吧，然后有人想到了一个主意，听着，我们在美国有装配线。所以让我们让他们以自助餐厅的方式进食。这更有效率。我们可以跟踪事情。好吧，工人们绝对讨厌那种方式。
They felt like they were being treated like cogs in a wheel and suddenly went on a rampage. And the town was practically destroyed. And one of the first targets were the time clocks. Which they smashed to pieces. Yes, the managers had to flee, right? The managers had to flee on boats and into the jungles, right? Because of the fury of this uprising. And the town was eventually retaken with the help of Brazilian security. And then rather than give up, Ford recommitted.
他们觉得他们被当作齿轮一样对待，突然就开始横冲直撞。城镇几乎被摧毁了。第一个目标之一就是考勤钟。他们把它们砸得粉碎。是的，经理们不得不逃跑，对吧？经理们不得不乘船逃进丛林，对吧？因为这次起义的愤怒。城镇最终在巴西安全部队的帮助下被夺回。然后福特没有放弃，而是重新投入。
Ford even more money into trying to realize this Midwestern ideal. At this point, Ford was only a few years into this Fordlandia experiment, and it wasn't paying off. But the company just kept pouring money into the rubber plantation. Grandin says there always seem to be a way
福特投入了更多的钱试图实现这个中西部理想。此时，福特在福特兰的实验才进行了几年，并没有得到回报。但公司只是不断地向橡胶种植园投入资金。格兰丁说，似乎总有一种方式
to justify the project. I mean, in the 1920s, it was going to be a symbol of what industrial capitalism could bring to the backwater of the Amazon. In the 1930s during the Depression, it becomes a symbol of how to survive the downturn. And besides, who was going to say no to Henry Ford? No one really had the gumption, the determination,
来证明这个项目的合理性。我的意思是，在20世纪20年代，它将成为工业资本主义能给亚马逊偏远地区带来什么的象征。在20世纪30年代大萧条期间，它成为了如何度过低迷期的象征。此外，谁会拒绝亨利·福特呢？没有人真正有勇气、决心，
the bravery, perhaps, to challenge Ford on these big decisions, because he was a tough fellow. More and more, as the years went by, he got set in his ways, and that was it. His word was what was going to happen. But Ford Landia was up against insurmountable challenges. More than the time clocks, more than the time clocks, more than the square dancing, more than the way meals were served.
也许是勇敢，去挑战福特在这些重大决定上的权威，因为他是一个强硬的人。随着岁月的流逝，他越来越固执己见，就是这样。他的话就是将要发生的事情。但福特兰面临着无法克服的挑战。不仅仅是考勤钟，不仅仅是考勤钟，不仅仅是方块舞，不仅仅是进餐方式。
The real problem was bugs, the insects, and fungi that were the rubber trees' natural predators in the Amazon. Ford hadn't really bothered to learn anything about botany or agronomy before embarking on his Fortlandia experiment. He didn't trust the experts that could have warned him what he was getting into. In fact, he didn't trust experts at all. He demeaned the idea of experts sort of slowing the progress of an idea. In his experience, they could go to the factory floor and maybe they had a problem with a widget or a wadget and they would have trial and error and they would just figure it out
真正的问题是虫子，那些在亚马逊是橡胶树天敌的昆虫和真菌。福特在开始他的福特兰实验之前，并没有费心去学习任何关于植物学或农学的东西。他不信任那些本可以警告他会陷入什么境地的专家。事实上，他根本不信任专家。他贬低专家的想法，认为这会减慢想法的进展。根据他的经验，他们可以去工厂车间，也许他们对一个小部件或小玩意有问题，他们会进行反复试验，他们就会弄明白
and they didn't need somebody with a title or an education and some specialty to tell them what to do. That was part of the problem with this that I think Ford bought into his own kind of invincibility, his own press if you will thinking that he could just go down there and take this kind of raw jungle and turn it into an industrial enterprise, a working industrial enterprise. And I think his eyes were bigger than his stomach, so to speak. His ambition's got ahead of his abilities in this case, because he wasn't willing to listen to the experts who wasn't willing to bring them on board.
他们不需要一个有头衔或受过教育且有某种专业知识的人来告诉他们该怎么做。我认为福特陷入了他自己那种无敌的错觉，他自己的新闻，如果你愿意的话，认为他可以去那里，把这种原始丛林变成一个工业企业，一个工作的工业企业。我认为他的眼睛比胃大，可以这么说。在这种情况下，他的野心超过了他的能力，因为他不愿听取专家的意见，也不愿让他们加入。
He was in far too deep the over his head. The problem was that rubber trees had never grown in the Amazon in the way that the Ford Company was trying to grow them. In dense plantations, with trees planted in tight rows. This growing style might have worked in the Southeast Asian plantations run by Europeans, but that's because the bugs there hadn't evolved to eat rubber trees. In Brazil, this density ended up creating an environment where native bugs that fed on rubber trees thrived.
他陷得太深，超出了他的能力范围。问题在于，橡胶树从未像福特公司试图种植的那样在亚马逊生长。在密集的种植园中，树木种植在紧密的行中。这种种植方式可能在欧洲人经营的东南亚种植园中有效，但那是因为那里的虫子还没有进化到吃橡胶树。在巴西，这种密度最终创造了一个环境，使得以橡胶树为食的本地虫子茁壮成长。
What Ford was basically doing was building a giant incubator, in which the bugs and the blight and the fungi that feed off of rubber was able to grow exponentially because the trees were close together. For example, there were these caterpillars that were very fond of rubber trees. One of the predators was caterpillars, right? And at first all of the caterpillars were on the bottom of the leaves, so for landia, the managers would send out battalions of workers to pick the caterpillar. And they even gathered all the caterpillars together and in buckets and then poured them
福特基本上是在建造一个巨大的孵化器，由于树木靠得很近，以橡胶为食的虫子、枯萎病和真菌能够呈指数级增长。例如，有这些非常喜欢橡胶树的毛毛虫。其中一个捕食者是毛毛虫，对吧？起初所有的毛毛虫都在叶子的底部，所以福特兰的经理们会派出工人大队去摘毛毛虫。他们甚至把所有的毛毛虫收集在桶里，然后倒出来
together and then had a huge bonfire. But within a few years, guess what happened? When the caterpillars weren't actually eating the leaves from the bottom, they were eating the leaves from the top. So you couldn't actually see them and so therefore you couldn't pick them. Again and again, they replanted the trees, only to have them killed off by pests. This went on for years, and then decades. It wasn't until 1945 that Ford finally decided to shut down Ford Landia. At that point, Henry Ford had turned the company over to his grandson, and Ford Landia with
然后举行了一场巨大的篝火晚会。但在几年内，你猜发生了什么？当毛毛虫实际上没有从底部吃叶子时，它们正在从顶部吃叶子。所以你实际上看不到它们，因此你无法摘除它们。他们一次又一次地重新种植树木，结果却被害虫杀死。这种情况持续了几年，然后是几十年。直到1945年，福特才最终决定关闭福特兰。那时，亨利·福特已经把公司交给了他的孙子，而福特兰也随之
it. And within a few months, he sold it back to the Brazilian government for like $250,000 and then it was over. Henry Ford died a couple years later, and after all the money and time invested, weirdly, he'd never even visit it for landia. He'd orchestrated all of it, right down to the square dances from his home thousands of miles away in Michigan. You know, part of it maybe he was just afraid of going and seeing the failure there in person, so to speak. I mean, he certainly was reading the reports,
一起。几个月内，他以大约25万美元的价格把它卖回给了巴西政府，然后一切都结束了。亨利·福特几年后去世了，在投入了所有的金钱和时间后，奇怪的是，他甚至从未访问过福特兰。他策划了这一切，甚至连方块舞都是在他远在密歇根州数千英里外的家中策划的。你知道，部分原因也许他只是害怕亲自去看看那里的失败，可以这么说。我的意思是，他肯定在阅读报告，
the memos, knew what was happening or what wasn't happening in Fort Lantia, so perhaps he didn't want to reckon with it personally. personally. Fordlandia is still a town today, and although a lot of the old buildings are now falling down, people continue to live there. Historian Greg Grandin has visited twice, that's two times more than Henry Ford ever did for those of you keeping count. Grandin made the day and a half long trip up the Toposos River by boat. You just turn, you just come around a bank and then all of a sudden you see this enormous
备忘录，知道福特兰正在发生什么或没有发生什么，所以也许他不想亲自面对它。亲自面对。福特兰今天仍然是一个城镇，虽然许多旧建筑现在正在倒塌，但人们继续住在那里。历史学家格雷格·格兰丁访问过两次，对于那些正在计数的人来说，这比亨利·福特访问的次数多两次。格兰丁乘船进行了长达一天半的塔帕若斯河之旅。你只是转弯，你只是绕过一个河岸，然后突然你看到这个巨大的
water tank and back in the day the word Ford was written on the water tank and you could see the outlines of what was for landia is still there. It's now a regular town. Brazilians are moved in and taken over all of the houses, but you still get a sense of what it looked like in the 1920s and 1930s. My house is very close. From my house, we can see the water tower. It's Ana Hita Soza and she's lived in Fort Landa since 2009. It's less than a kilometer. We can see it.
水箱，在过去，福特这个词写在水箱上，你可以看到福特兰的轮廓仍然在那里。它现在是一个普通的城镇。巴西人搬进来并接管了所有的房子，但你仍然能感觉到它在20世纪20年代和30年代的样子。我的房子很近。从我的房子，我们可以看到水塔。她是安娜·希塔·索萨，她自2009年以来一直住在福特兰。不到一公里。我们可以看到它。
The water tower is beautiful. It's historic. It's a wonderful thing to see. There aren't many jobs left in the area for the 2000 inhabitants of Fort Landia. Most of the economy in the region now revolves around industrial soybean production and cattle ranches. There's a little bit of tourism too, which people like Sosa count on. She works at a hotel in town. We receive people from all countries.
水塔很漂亮。它是历史性的。这是一件值得一看的美妙事情。福特兰的2000名居民在该地区剩下的工作不多了。该地区的大部分经济现在围绕着工业大豆生产和养牛场。也有一些旅游业，索萨这样的人指望它。她在镇上的一家酒店工作。我们接待来自各个国家的人。
They search for the history. They are curious to see in person this history. What is left? There are a few things yet. They come to see the village, the big houses, the school, the cemetery, the hospital. People come to see what's left of Ford's crazy vision. The American style town in the middle of the Brazilian jungle, the culturally insensitive and paternalistic boom doggo that, for all its
他们寻找历史。他们好奇地想亲自看看这段历史。还剩下什么？还有一些东西。他们来看村庄、大房子、学校、墓地、医院。人们来看福特疯狂愿景的残余。在巴西丛林中央的美式小镇，那个文化不敏感且家长式的浪费钱的项目，尽管它有所有的
faults, still created good pain jobs for its workers. e foi muito audacioso. a lot of jobs for resilience. People from all over Brazil migrated to here looking for a job. Soza wasn't there to see all the ways for landia went wrong. For her, the history represents a time when this sleepy town was the focus of a massive experiment by a world famous industrialist. Now with its crumbling old buildings, Fort Landia is a different kind of lost civilization than you'd expect to find in the middle of the Amazon. A Midwest fantasy land returning to the jungle.
缺点，仍然为它的工人创造了好的高薪工作。它非常大胆。为巴西人提供了很多工作。来自巴西各地的人们迁移到这里寻找工作。索萨并没有在那里看到福特兰出错的所有方式。对她来说，这段历史代表了一个时代，当时这个沉睡的小镇是一个世界著名工业家进行大规模实验的焦点。现在，随着它摇摇欲坠的旧建筑，福特兰是一种不同于你在亚马逊中部所期望发现的失落文明。一个回归丛林的美国中西部幻想之地。
Do you know I host and produce another show? It's about the Constitution, Twitter, and Trump, and it's actually really fun. It's called What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law. And this week is the last episode of the second series of that show, and I'm going to talk about it with my co-presenter, Elizabeth Jo, right after this. So I host another radiotopia podcast called What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law. And in it I invite over my friend and neighbor Elizabeth Jo to teach me a little about constitutional law using tweets from Trump as a jumping off point.
你知道我主持并制作了另一个节目吗？它是关于宪法、推特和特朗普的，而且实际上非常有趣。它叫《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法》。本周是该节目第二系列的最后一集，我将和我的联合主持人伊丽莎白·乔讨论它，就在这之后。所以我主持了另一个名为《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法》的RadioTopia播客。在节目中，我邀请我的朋友和邻居伊丽莎白·乔，利用特朗普的推文作为切入点，教我一点关于宪法的内容。
So for example, the episode coming out this week starts with Trump's tweet about giving guns to teachers in school. And then we use that premise to look at the Fourth Amendment and what it says about the use of deadly force by the government. Usually the government employee that would potentially use deadly force is a cop, not a teacher, but the world has gone crazy. Presidents have always pushed against the Constitution in different ways to forward their agenda. But the reason why Trump is such a good foil for these types of hypothetical discussions
例如，本周播出的这一集以特朗普关于给学校教师配枪的推文开始。然后我们利用这个前提来审视第四修正案以及它关于政府使用致命武力的规定。通常，可能使用致命武力的政府雇员是警察，而不是老师，但世界已经疯了。总统们总是以不同的方式推动宪法以推进他们的议程。但特朗普之所以成为这些假设性讨论的良好陪衬
about the Constitution is because we have this unique window into what he's thinking because of Twitter. We've never had sort of direct access to a president's thoughts, his id, his moment-by-moment thoughts on every piece of news or policy, which may only hold for the next five minutes, but nevertheless, we get as snapshot into what he's thinking. And that's been important because this has been a norm breaking presidency. It's almost
关于宪法，是因为我们通过推特对他的想法有一个独特的窗口。我们从未以这种方式直接接触过总统的想法，他的本我，他对每一条新闻或政策的即时想法，这可能只在接下来的五分钟内有效，但尽管如此，我们还是得到了他想法的快照。这很重要，因为这是一个打破常规的总统任期。现在说这是不正常的，这几乎
a tired phrase now to say this is abnormal. I mean, the abnormal has become normal. And in some ways, that's been the genesis of this whole series. And Trump has definitely changed the way that Elizabeth teaches constitutional law at UC Davis. When I sort of survey my class and ask like, what would you like to talk about this semester? We'll try to address some of those things. They're all Trump related. They all want to know basically, you know, whatever the topic is, can he do that? Is he allowed to do that? And I think that's been what's really remarkable. And so yeah, it's very different to be a student, I think, in a teacher of constitutional law. It's very different just to be an American today
是一个陈词滥调。我的意思是，不正常已经变成了正常。在某种程度上，这就是整个系列的起源。特朗普绝对改变了伊丽莎白在加州大学戴维斯分校教授宪法的方式。当我调查我的班级并问，这个学期你们想谈论什么？我们会尝试解决其中的一些事情。它们都与特朗普有关。他们基本上都想知道，你知道，无论主题是什么，他能那样做吗？他被允许那样做吗？我认为这才是真正引人注目的地方。所以是的，我认为作为一名学生和一名宪法教师是非常不同的。今天作为一名美国人是非常不同的
to think about what's normal in terms of expecting certain kind of behavior out of an American president. That's totally changed. We're using this opportunity to teach people about the constitution in new ways. And that seems to be going on beyond the reach of this podcast. Is that a silver lining that you see in all this that people are actually talking about the Fourth
去思考在期望美国总统表现出某种行为方面什么是正常的。这完全改变了。我们正在利用这个机会以新的方式教人们关于宪法。这似乎正在超出这个播客的范围。你认为这是你在这一切中看到的希望吗，人们实际上在谈论第四
Amendment and the 10th Amendment? Do you take pleasure in that? Yes, that has to be the one silver lining that people actually want to learn about how the government works. And that people are slowly discovering that despite the fact that we have a constitution and we have so many Supreme Court decisions on a variety of topics, the real thing that was always binding us, the cohesion, the glue for society was norms, that it wasn't the law, the law came second,
修正案和第十修正案？你从中获得乐趣吗？是的，这必须是唯一的希望，人们实际上想了解政府是如何运作的。人们正在慢慢发现，尽管我们有宪法，我们有关于各种主题的许多最高法院判决，但真正一直约束我们的东西，凝聚力，社会的粘合剂是规范，而不是法律，法律是次要的，
that the norms actually make our shared experience of what government should be possible. And when those start to unravel, people are understandably nervous. So that's been a big learning experience for all of us. Do you have a greater sense that we are dependent on norms than you did, I don't know, 18 months ago? Sure, absolutely. I mean, it's showing us that,
规范实际上使我们对政府应该是什么的共同体验成为可能。当这些开始瓦解时，人们感到紧张是可以理解的。所以这对我们所有人来说都是一个巨大的学习经历。你是否比18个月前更强烈地感觉到我们依赖于规范？当然，绝对是。我的意思是，它向我们展示了，
you know, what we need is this kind of collective faith that our institutions are collective faith in what the president should and should not be doing. And when that starts to come apart, I think that that raises new kinds of questions for how we ought to think about all of these offices and institutions, Congress, the president, how law works, what we should think about courts. I mean, we've never really had this kind of ultimate question begging moment. What does this all mean?
你知道，我们需要这种集体信仰，即我们的机构是对总统应该做什么和不应该做什么的集体信仰。当这种情况开始瓦解时，我认为这为我们应该如何思考所有这些办公室和机构，国会，总统，法律如何运作，我们应该如何思考法院提出了新的问题。我的意思是，我们从未真正有过这种终极的质疑时刻。这一切意味着什么？
In the very, very beginning, when we started this show, we talked about the constitution having only 5,000 words, and it's just the scaffolding that can be interpreted in a lot of ways. Do you kind of wish now that there were more words in the constitution that it was a little more exact? No, I don't think so, because I think there's, I mean, one of the reasons why so far anyway, our system has been remarkably resilient and long I mean, one of the reasons why so far anyway, our system has been remarkably resilient and long-lasting is because of the flexibility and the document. You know, if they, we had spent specific that, you know, you can't use muskets and every
在最开始，当我们开始这个节目时，我们谈到宪法只有5000字，它只是可以以多种方式解释的脚手架。你现在是否有点希望宪法中有更多的字，它更精确一点？不，我不这么认为，因为我认为有，我的意思是，到目前为止，我们的系统之所以非常具有韧性和持久性，其中一个原因，我的意思是，到目前为止，我们的系统之所以非常具有韧性和持久性，是因为文档的灵活性。你知道，如果他们，我们花费了具体，你知道，你不能使用火枪，每个人
person should pay, you know, one dollar in taxes. It would be a very different document and probably we would have abandoned it a long time ago. But it's the open-endedness of it, which kind of shows the genius of the original framers, I think, to show that they were writing a document that was supposed to last for a long time. Now the problem with that is that we end up arguing a lot about what that means. And so that's kind of the thrilling part of constitutional law or had been. And now sometimes it's becoming the scary part of constitutional law. So if you want to take the chaos of unhinged tweets and endless political news and channel
都应该支付，你知道，一美元的税。那将是一份非常不同的文件，可能我们很久以前就放弃它了。但它的开放性，我认为这显示了最初制定者的天才，表明他们正在写一份应该持续很长时间的文件。现在的问题是，我们最终会为这意味着什么争论很多。所以这算是宪法中令人兴奋的部分，或者曾经是。现在有时它正在成为宪法中可怕的部分。所以如果你想把混乱的推文和无休止的政治新闻引导
that into learning the Constitution. I welcome you to join me as a fellow student on what Trump can teach us about Khan Law. Can Trump fire Mueller? Can Trump harden himself? What does it mean when Trump questions the legitimacy of judges? Can he even seize the necessary land to construct a border wall? Elizabeth Jo explains it all on what Trump can teach us about Conn Laugh.
到学习宪法中。我欢迎你加入我，作为《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法》的同学。特朗普能解雇穆勒吗？特朗普能赦免自己吗？当特朗普质疑法官的合法性时，这意味着什么？他甚至可以征用必要的土地来建造边境墙吗？伊丽莎白·乔在《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法》中解释了一切。
We call it Trump Conn Laugh, for sure. Find it on Apple Podcasts, Radio Public, or wherever you download podcasts. 99% Invisible What's Produced This Week By Our Senior Editor Delaney Hall, Mixed In Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Rial, Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colesstedt is the digital director. The rest of the staff includes Avery Trouffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Teran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Thanks to Roger Weber and Zach Rosen, the host and producer of the Mismatch podcast, from the Graham Media Group and WDIV local four in Detroit, we
我们肯定称它为“特朗普宪法”。在苹果播客、Radio Public或任何你下载播客的地方找到它。99%隐形，本周由我们的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔制作，技术制作由谢里夫·优素福混合，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作，凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯泰特是数字总监。其余员工包括艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎和我，罗曼·马尔斯。感谢罗杰·韦伯和扎克·罗森，Mismatch播客的主持人和制片人，来自底特律的格雷厄姆媒体集团和WDIV当地四台，我们
adapted the Fortlandia story from them. Thanks also to Paula Moota for production and translation help. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook, you can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork, on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have all kinds of pictures of Ford Landia, and they are weird and definitely worth
改编了他们的福特兰故事。也感谢保拉·穆塔在制作和翻译方面的帮助。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Radio Row制作。99%隐形是PRX RadioTopia的创始成员，这是一个播客中最优秀、最具创新性的节目集合。我们得到像你一样的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论，你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。但我们有各种各样的福特兰图片，它们很奇怪，绝对值得一看
a gander, at 99pi.org. Radio tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在99pi.org。PRX的RadioTopia。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。